foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off mortgage
has taken the place of the BMW as the
status symbol of choice I'm Dave Ramsey
your host Ken Coleman of Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your money your career
and of course actual amazing
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Paula is going to start us off this hour
in San Antonio Texas hey Paula how are
you
on this fine day even you better than I
deserve what's up
that's me however I'm trying to find out
if I'm doing the right thing for
considering my situation I'm not trying
to be an Elon Musk or a Bill Gates I'm
very happy at what I got and um just
want to live comfortable and I'm doing
that but I have my mortgage paid off
I am 76 years old
and I don't work I could but I don't I
just choose not to
I have a 2600 a month Social Security
coming in I have over a hundred thousand
dollars in a money market
I have 31 000 in a savings
and I uh save a thousand dollars a month
my bills are all paid at the first of
every month
am I doing the right thing
okay so you have no Investments at all
no uh that's right now I am too scared
of that with the market so fallible and
everything going haywire I don't want to
play with the market okay I just want to
be comfortable and happy and and
basically I am I just want to know if
that's going to carry me through to my
you know I'm I'm 70 I'm a young 76 year
old but you're not using the money
no absolutely not if you continue like
you continue it would carry you on to
176.
well I plan to live that I know I can
tell I can tell so uh me too more
interview than a 60 year old no I'm
serious that that you're not using the
money and so no you know it's if you
were burning it if you were going
through it a little bit if you were you
know eating a thousand dollars a month
out of it uh to live but you're living
on your Social Security is what you're
saying I'm
yeah okay I mean if that makes you happy
I'm not going to change it
no I'm happy dude I just want to know if
I'm if that's really the right thing to
do for me
it sounds like it is because it's what
makes you happy
yeah
you know if it was me and
um you know I'm 62. I've got my uh money
in excess of an emergency fund uh if I
had that extra hundred thousand I'm I am
investing it into some good mutual funds
that have a long stable track record
um because I'm not scared of the market
and that would not cause me to lay awake
at night but it sounds to me like that
that would cause you to lay awake at
night so you shouldn't do it
well it would because you see everything
going up and down up and down and all
the predictions that we're going to have
a crash and all this you know right I
mean let's just you you and I are old
enough that we've heard that every year
our entire life
and it never happened
well
I don't I I believe what you're saying
but I'm going to kind that knows
no can't there's always their kids can
go broke
is in a money market Choice Money Market
now if the banks go broke or I know it's
it's federally insured or is it with a
bank
well actually it's with a uh savings uh
a credit union
they've got ncua so yeah that's it I
never get those that quick but you've
got the same you know you've got
insurance on the money if the credit
union goes belly up and then the
government would have to go belly up
which is possible too
oh yeah the way they act yeah and then
you would not get your money and so that
you know that's your absolute worst case
scenario now and if you invest the money
uh it could go up and down up and down
up and down uh but likely you know
there's no track record of it
disappearing either so but I I I'm not
gonna push on it I mean uh Paula this is
making you happy yeah and you're saving
I just want to be sure I'm kind of doing
the right thing that goes like I said I
put back well it's costing it's costing
you about ten thousand dollars a year
it's costing me ten thousand a year yeah
if it was invested you'd be making about
a 10 rate of return on average and good
mutual funds and on a hundred thousand
that's ten thousand dollars a year so
you're missing out on about ten thousand
dollars a year but you know it sounds to
me like it sounds to me like that's an
insurance policy causes you to sleep and
I'm not going to argue with you about it
well that's that's what I wanted to know
then you know that's all I needed to
know that I'm kind of okay with where
I'm at then you're not gonna go broke
you're more than okay Paula you couldn't
do something done with money if you
tried I just don't think she's got it in
her name she's so wise well I mean the
thing is this now let's just talk back
up and talk about it number one that's
her situation and her and her I don't
think in one radio conversation I'm
going to cause her to have peace with
investing but I will challenge all of
you out there to the tune of ten
thousand dollars a year
uh to me that means it's time for me to
learn something and
um now when she bought her home
house prices go up and down
she did not get a guarantee from the
federal government or the ncua
our house price could go down tomorrow
but she's not concerned about that you
know why most of us when we buy them we
don't think about the fact that it's not
federally guaranteed the reason is track
record and track record matters
it does and we you know we were just
going through this all the Ramsey
personalities walking through it with
you uh in a room and we were looking at
this crazy awesome uh poster essentially
that they opened up wide and they showed
the history of the stock market and they
showed how it did
before and after some of the biggest
events in American history when you
would think it would create a lot of
fear and instability and it did short
term but then it always came back and I
think that was one of the most powerful
illustrations I'd ever seen on what you
teach and what you have been teaching
well and track record is the thing why
are you comfortable buying a home with
no guarantee no federally insured
guarantee right because homes if you got
walking around sense of generally gone
up over the scope of your life I mean
first house I sold when I was 18 years
old was 42
000 250 to a kid from my high school now
that kid wouldn't smart he bought a
house from an 18 year old but anyway
um yeah but I and you know turned out to
be a really smart idea because that
house today would probably be 350 400
000 right sure but that's a long time
ago but I mean we've all got walking
around since we can look and say okay
the track record of real estate is I'm
not going to lose all my money it might
have a little bump in the road but I'm
not gonna lose all my money and if you
actually look at the stock market you
know with good mutual fund investing
good Diversified investing you're not
going to lose all your money there's
gonna be some bumps in the road and
you're gonna make money now that's the
truth but you need to get comfortable
with that track record in that history
like you did that piece of real estate
and then you can sleep at night never
invest because Dave Ramsey said to
always invest never invest because
anybody said to except you
you need to get comfortable with it you
need to understand what you're putting
money in and then when you understand
that history I got a lot of Peace about
putting money in the market no trouble
for it no trouble with it for me at all
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys if you like this show and you
want to help us out since we're doing it
for you for free
you can help us out we'd appreciate it a
couple things you can do you can
subscribe to the show on YouTube or
podcast or follow or whatever you do on
your particular version of how you
consume the show you can leave a review
five stars no need to leave one star
mama said if you ain't anything nice to
say don't say anything at all and you
can share this with a friend just tell
them where you're listening on talk
radio or that you're watching on TBN or
that you are you can click the link and
share it if it's YouTube or a podcast
link so just to spread the word for us
let people know that would be a huge
help to us it uh it really does matter
it affects the all the algorithms and
all the things and causes us to be
served up and so forth and uh just uh
just about a week ago I think where the
number 19 podcast in the world
in size in terms of uh I've had over a
billion downloads of the show now and uh
100 of that's because you guys told
someone so thank you thank you thank you
for doing that Sarah's in Houston hi
Sarah welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve how can we help
good well I have a
chance we went through a job change
after nearly 15 years with my previous
employer who I started with right out of
college so this is a pretty big shift
um so I'm trying to figure out is what
are the reasons timeline for feeling
settled with this new job meaning that
you're understanding processes You're
Building those relationships with people
and it's just understanding how things
work and then the second question is how
do I discern if if kind of the
overwhelming stress that I'm feeling is
normal for starting with a new company
after such a long time with a different
company and or if it could be a symptom
of a larger problem how long you been
there
um I started it's been about four months
what do you do
I'll project manager
okay yeah so I there's no set rule on
how long it takes somebody to get
settled there's no there's no just hard
and fast rule but I will tell you that
uh being settled will happen when you
get over some of the natural fears and
doubts of starting something new that's
just natural I don't care what area of
life we're talking about we've been
doing something for a very long time in
15 years is a long time it's the only
culture you've ever known the way they
did work at that last company was all
you've ever known so I I think the
settling will take care of itself I
think the the bigger thing that I want
to know is what are your concerns what
are you feeling concerned about right
now I want to find out if there's some
depth to that or if that's just kind of
some natural stuff going on yeah I mean
I I guess that my previous employer I
felt confident that I had built a very a
good reputation and that you know my my
loyalty to the company and my I always
had the company's best interest in my
heart so if I made a mistake you know it
was kind of like okay well you know
we'll work through that at a new company
it's all new it's all new people and I
have a lot of responsibility and this is
the exact kind of job that I've been
wanting so I I love it okay so also just
afraid that's 100 what's going on so
let's let's start with reality in four
months time you cannot build a
reputation you can make an impression
you can build a bad reputation yeah yeah
you can that's right but but a good
reputation is developed over time so
right now we're trying to make a good
impression and and you're really worried
and I understand that but here's the
deal if you look back on your past job
you developed the reputation to where if
a mistake was made they understood this
is a rarity and this is not a character
problem and it's out of Competency
problem is just the natural workflow we
all make mistakes but you develop that
over time so give yourself a break you
got to remember your history you
developed it before you'll develop it
again and so what right now this is a
mindset thing so here's a little
exercise when you start to feel that
fear and kind of worry pop up during the
day you need to just find yourself a
quiet moment even it's just shutting
down uh the email you people think
you're looking at your computer but
you're just going to run through a
mental exercise is this fear have any
evidence does this fear have any
evidence that it's true
and if it has no evidence that it's true
we know that it's our mind and it's
based on fear and it's going to hold me
back and so then we flush it if it's
true then that means fear is protecting
you from something but in this case you
have no history at all that says that
you're going to make a bunch of mistakes
at this new company in a job that you've
longed for and you worked hard for
there's no evidence that says you're
going to create a bunch of problems and
mistakes that they're going to fire you
you would have to really intentionally
do something boneheaded to get to that
place true or false
true all right true so believe in
yourself invest in yourself and operate
in confidence because you've been there
before
yeah that's fair that's very fair
okay
anytime you do anything for 15 years
doing the same thing in a different
place is going to take a little while
period whether it's job or job whether
it's a relationship whether it's uh you
know you change cars you've been driven
one kind of car and you get a different
kind of car it's going to feel weird
going down the highway I mean it just
takes a little while it's just uh
whatever the thing is and so because our
human mind gets in a groove or a rut one
of the two and um you know and now you
bumped up out of that and you're in the
uh you're in the land of Adventure
darling you know it's not unlike
um when you when you've grown up so we
went to dinner with a young couple the
other night Dave uh Stacy and I and they
just got married Stacy and I are coming
up on 25 years and they were just saying
what advice would you give us and Stacy
gave some great advice way better than
mine but one of the things I said was is
that realize that first year is so
difficult because you've grown up in one
home and both of you've grown up in
different homes where there was a rhythm
of how life was done so maybe the dad
did things this way in your home but the
dad completely did something different
over here and so you both are bringing
expectations based on the environment
you you grew up in and all of a sudden
you get two completely different
expectations because of different
experiences and environments and so you
got to learn to adjust to each other in
marriage and I think this is a very
similar situation all she ever knew was
the way that company did work and a
company has a very unique culture if you
come to Ramsey Solutions and you've
never been in a place like this before
man it it'll blow your mind how we care
for each other how we communicate so
unbelievably clearly uh very
intentionally it's so any place good or
bad is going to take some time because
it's a really different environment yep
I mean it just takes a minute takes a
minute to get your footing it's so
simple so Sarah I like what you did
though
I like your spirit of Adventure yeah I
like that you stepped out on this I said
I'm gonna go do something big it's time
it's time to shake off the cobwebs and
yeah good for you good for you it's
going to pay off for you it's going to
pay off for you good stuff movana is
with us in DC hey bavana what's up
hi Mr MZ thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
sure so I am 23 years old and I'm going
to be starting medical school in a few
months congratulations thank you I want
to first of all say I'm super blessed I
was able to go to
for almost next to nothing and so most
of my 529 I think will cover all of my
medical education expenses yes my my
parents were really generous with that
and um I'm almost certain it'll cover
all the expenses but I do have thirty
thousand dollars in savings and so I'm
wondering whether I should keep uh how
to kind of divvy that up in terms of
whether I should keep some of it just in
case I have a couple thousand dollars
left over that I do need to end up
paying for if I should start investing
because I know my retirement investments
will be probably four to six years
delayed compared to most people who are
starting work now yeah it'll be four to
six times more income
so I think you'll be okay
listen the best possible investment
bubonic can make right now is in bhuvana
you are what's known as a cash machine
you are getting ready to make some
serious bank because dumb people don't
get into med school
they don't let them in and so um you
know you're going to go through this
you're going to graduate you're going to
pass your boards and doing all of that
with zero debt and starting off your
career with zero debt is the best
investment you can possibly make you are
a better return on investment than a
mutual fund is
that's good for now yeah so just trap
all that money and I want you listen you
did a lot of planning
you did a lot of uh scheming and
scamming you've laid everything out
you've dreamed about this in detail now
do the same thing for the money part of
it
you sound a little bit kind of
wishy-washy and disorganized about
whether the money's actually going to
make it or not I want you to sit down
and develop a plan where the money makes
it
your money makes it and graduate with
thirty thousand dollars still in the
bank that'll be great I want you to lay
out a detailed
HD high definition
game plan to get through med school with
the money you've got and that's going to
keep you from buying stupid butt stuff
when you're tired stressed out taking
some tests in the middle of the night
and so seriously lay it out in detail
this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
if you've got debt
and now you got inflation stealing more
and more of your paycheck
I know a lot of folks out there feel
like you're drowning
scared
I understand I've been there it's no fun
and you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress
if you want things to change though let
me tell you who's going to change them
you
you've got to finally back up and say
that's it
I've had it
when you've had your eye I've had it
moment the next thing you need to know
is how do I fix this dadgum mess I made
let me tell you what I've got the
solution for 30 years we've had 10
million people now go through Financial
Peace University our nine lesson course
that'll teach you how to get out of debt
become wealthy and outrageously generous
and it really does work
it is the largest course on how to
handle money in America today by far
nobody's even close
check it out if you want to know more
about it just go to
ramsesolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com
FPU and we can show you how to walk away
from the fear is it going to be easy
well crap no it's not going to be easy
making the mess was easy getting out of
it isn't going to be easy
and it's going to take you about half as
long to get out as it took you to get in
so if you've made a mess for four years
count on about two years to get your
butt out not two minutes we don't sell
microwaves around here food isn't worth
eating
we sell crock pots
No Such Thing Ken I've been all over
America I've never seen anybody put the
phrase good
microwave barbecue in one sentence
that's exactly right there's no such
thing nope no such thing you got to cook
it until the dog next door is howling
low and slow that's it man you just you
gotta take the animals animals have to
be stirred up from the smoke that's how
it works and and life is that way the
good stuff that's true you know it
requires putting some calluses on your
brain and on your hands it requires
doing some things you've never done and
being uncomfortable because comfortable
is what got you into the dadgum mess
that's the deal open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Alec is in Atlanta hi Alec
how are you
hey guys so much for thinking of my call
sure what's up
so I recently completed baby step three
and within the next two to three years
I'm gonna have to get a newer car good
and when the time comes I just want to
know should I use my emergency fund to
pay for this newer car or should I you
know start saving up money in a
completely different savings account we
call it an emergency fund because you
use it for emergencies
buying a car that you plan to buy a year
and a half from now is not an emergency
so you save up and pay for it
aside from your emergency fund don't
touch your emergency fund for something
that's not an emergency
does that make sense
clears mud okay well don't use your
emergency buying a car is not an
emergency unless your car just
disappeared last night you had no
insurance
sure now that's an emergency okay or the
car gets totaled and you had no
insurance right that would be an
emergency but right now you're telling
me I got 18 months to save up for a car
that's not an emergency
buying tires going on vacation Christmas
is not an emergency it's always in
December they don't move it
follow the difference an emergency is
known as an unexpected event
you've clearly made this an expected
event yeah so there you go that that
hopefully that clears the mud up but
yeah that's what we're going to do there
save up and pay cash for it and by the
way anything else you buy for the rest
of your life you're going to save up and
pay cash so you don't fall back into
debt
fall back
most people don't fall into that they
strut oh yeah sometimes they jump into
it they jump into it like a jumping into
the death okay you know there's a hold
on before you go there Dave because this
is interesting I'm just listening to
that and hit the psychology going on and
he's wrestling with that and I think
there's some other people maybe knew the
show that are kind of wrestling with
that too well Dave the car is just not
going to last much more than 18 months
why can't I use the emergency fund and I
think it's the difference between the
expected and the unexpected and there it
gets back to this financial peace phrase
we use all the time on this show why are
we so clear on that to say Hey you know
you need a car why is it a better
financial decision to save up for that
than it is to just go ahead and use that
money that's already saved no the same
because here's let's just be real clear
if you use your emergency fund you have
to stop everything you're doing and
replenish it that's because you're gonna
otherwise you're going to attract an
emergency right so um yeah it's not
I used to work with a guy a thousand
years ago he said people use their
savings account as a put and take
account put in take it out
put in take it out put in take it out
and and they never have any savings as a
result
it's just a it's a glorified checking
account that lasts a little bit longer
than two weeks you know that's good so
it's a put and take account and if you
if you use your savings that way instead
of using a named account okay this this
account has a name emergency fund we
don't touch it except for emergencies
this account is the car account and if I
use that money to buy a couch no car
right if it's the couch account and I
use it to buy a car no couch so you by
naming it you realize you're violating
your former intention because you're
being an impulsive little child that's
typically what happens with me anyway
that's right it's not a bass boat
account I mean really seriously those
fish are not going to outrun you it's
okay and so you can get us you can go
with the old slow motor it'll work it
gets you there it's they're still going
to be in the lake and uh but you know we
have to go 126 miles an hour apparently
to catch a bass because they're really
fast so increase a boundary a real
mental boundary developed over time of
discipline to say we're not touching
this and then we begin to adjust to that
it is a boundary and
and it's a muscle in the same sense you
know like one of the things I did for
years and years and years I don't do it
formally this way anymore I've got a
different process now that we have the
Family Foundation but I did giving that
way yeah and it was an interesting thing
once I moved money out of my checking
account into the generosity account
I didn't feel like I owned it anymore
right it was gone I just hadn't placed
it yeah that's good you know what I mean
and that wasn't sure but that was just a
psychological thing that by renaming it
I had released the ownership of it
already to generosity and so it wasn't
hard for me to give then when a need
came up in front of us it was just
because it was already in a sense given
and now when we move it into the Ramsey
Family Foundation it's the same thing
it's just a little bit more formal a
little bit more sophisticated with
Denise running all of our giving and all
that but the uh uh but but still I still
think I mean
if you just earmark it for something
then you feel like you're violating
something if you don't use it for that
yeah I
same thing happened to Stacy and I when
we first started the envelope system
because then it was like I would second
guess that's what you're supposed to do
if I know but it's like don't use your
food food money out of your food
envelope put gas in the car right
because you can't eat cash so it's not
food
so it's not an emergency you don't use
the emergency fund it's not a yeah and
we don't use your car fund for an
emergency unless it's a huge emergency
and you had to liquidate everything else
but by then what you're doing is you're
realizing you're you're setting up
boundaries like you said it put in place
to make yourself realizing you are
changing plans yes and you have to say I
am changing plans and really and if
you're married you're talking to your
spouse about that and you're going we
are getting ready to use the car money
to go to Europe or you're getting that
okay or we're going to uh use the Europe
money to get a car whatever it is
because we're changing the plan and uh
instead of like instead of just living
with this uh waves of impulse yes coming
over us and you you own it so you can
change it I could take money back out of
that generosity account and buy a car
with it I can't do that but it's a
change of plan and it would feel weird
it's kind of like here's another one
that comes up if you ever move money if
you ever push some money even if it's
birthday money or something in a kid's
savings account well the kid doesn't own
any money in America until they're 18.
you can't do contract law so that
account is not in the kid's name it's in
the parent's name as a with the the
kid's name of the parents is a custodian
you cannot you cannot do business until
you're 18. and so technically kids don't
own money
shocking I know that technically they
don't and so I could take that kid's
money and buy a car with it
because it's not really their money but
wouldn't that feel gross yes absolutely
that would feel gross I feel like I had
done something like a bad parent or
something because you would be this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're a new listener and you want to
get deeper into all this backstory stuff
like baby steps and debt snowballs go to
ramsesolutions.com click on the get
started button
it's completely free by the way and
we'll help you figure out the best next
step for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today we will show
you what to do next
based on years and years and years of
research and experience with our
customers and success
so get started click it at
ramsesolutions.com if you're brand new
we'll get you moving Jefferson Toledo hi
Jeff welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call my
friend I just want to tell you right up
front that uh
um your riveting messages meant a lot to
my family over the years and we did FPU
about 14 years ago changed my life
changed my family tree thank you for
that honored thank you
no problem
um my main question is I think I did a
little bit of a boo-boo Dave and I'm I'm
kind of retracting from it and and I I I
I have a feeling that your answer is
going to end up being not exactly what
you want to say or what's best interest
for me and my family and here's why so
basically my wife passed away about a
year and a half ago of ovarian cancer oh
my wonderful Christian woman I'm sorry
um she was a warrior she was she was she
went through FPU with me many years ago
it wasn't necessarily her strength I was
the nerd and family and and uh took care
of the finances but she
while during this cancer Journey says I
think we I need to leave a legacy for
our adult children our upcoming adult
children
and I said well how do you feel you want
to do this she said I think we need to
go to the title lawyer and include our
kids in on the on the and do a quick
claim deed and include them in on 25 of
the equity in her home which we have 100
equity on a home in Findlay Ohio that's
uh Worth right about between 750 and
800k
so I really don't uh so what I did is I
was in the midst of
really all hands on deck with her
ovarian cancer journey and it was very
difficult and I wasn't really in my
right mind and I signed it
and I think that
um releasing this money because I'm
actually getting married to a wonderful
gal from Dallas Texas and she's
incredible we have a long distance
relationship long story short I really
feel that I'm putting the house up on
the market and we've already got a
couple potential buyers
I know the children are my daughter's 18
senior in high school and my son is 21
down in in Orlando and so basically
what's going to happen is when we sell
this home we're going to get to the tune
of about 175k to 200k each
and I feel like it's going to be it's
not going to teach them the right things
um yes
got 25 percent
yes I signed the quick claim deeds you
didn't give them a quarter you gave them
a quarter each
a quarter each so if you sell it for
800k 200 Grand yeah I got you okay
all right and um I feel like it's
teaching them the wrong message and if
they get they're getting a windfall at a
very young age now granted they have the
right to do what they want with the
money
and I want to get your opinion on is it
is am I not a man of principle if I if I
try to retract this and let's get them
signed back off of it
before we fill his house or is it a good
idea to just follow through with my
commitment that I made with my wife
because she wanted to leave a legacy for
our kids
um
hmm
trying to think what I would do a good
way to solve ethics questions is get on
the other side and walk in the moccasins
treat other people like you'd want to be
treated kind of thing and so um I do not
hear you wanting to take this money and
buy your new wife a Mercedes I hear you
uh worried about your kids being
burdened with the weight of this that's
what I heard you say and so you are
putting their best interest at heart so
that does not make you lacking in
principle it makes you quite the
opposite
um what would I do if I were in your
shoes uh
because we do want to carry this Equity
into their our home that we want to live
we want to live in Atlanta I think what
I would do for sure is
um I would do a will immediately
and uh and a prenup
that protects their portion
uh were you to pass
okay and so and then I would ask them I
would ask somebody to eat it back to you
and then you say I'm going to leave you
all of the money from this house if I
die
and at a later Point
um you know as you guys get a little bit
older I'm going to help you with some
other things anyway but you're going to
end up getting this all the money from
the house not just of fourth each you're
going to get a 50 each when I die and uh
because I'm going to protect that with a
prenup and I'm going to protect that
with a will
but my children are pretty bound and
determined to get this money Dave oh
well that's they're not going to sign
the quit claim if they don't want to
sign a quick claim they really want to
sign it they don't want to sign it they
don't you can't make them sign it yeah
I'm worried about the relational I'm
worried about the relation last but I
think Dave's right you know put yourself
in your kids shoes to the best of your
ability you say you've told them this
this was your this was their mothers
dying wish you told them it was going to
happen and now you're changing your mind
and we're not questioning the principle
of the change but you have to put
yourself in their shoes and what is this
going to do to your relationship and I
think you have to consider that because
that to me is the bigger long-term issue
yeah yeah you add it you added color to
this equation when you said they didn't
want to do it that was the first part
first time in the conversation we heard
that part so that does yesterday now
again they're going based on hey this is
our mother's wishes this is what we see
because it was now I was a little queasy
wow I don't care you did I wasn't in my
right mind yeah you did it
um I did it yeah this would have been
the good time for the nerd to say no
thank you that's a bad plan
uh they're going to get it all when I
they're going to get it all when I die
anyway and no I'm not giving it giving
them a fourth of the quick claim sorry
you know that would have been the
conversation at our house but you know
so that's water under the bridge now now
you got two kids that are expecting this
and don't want to sign the quit claim
you are going to step in a relationship
hole here
uh and rightly so but I don't think it's
a matter of you're a man of principle
that's not the point uh the the point is
more the relational thing that's going
to get violated here and so I think I
think they got the money dude I think
you screwed up
I'm sorry no yeah that my title lawyer
just told me the same thing well there's
no question from a title standpoint you
can't do nothing but I was early in the
conversation I was under the impression
you could get them to be willing to sign
the title back over to you and now
you're saying they don't want to do that
you can't make them
is it wrong for me to persuade them and
get counsel to reverse that so that we
don't
you know what a what a tangled where we
could weave here if you can persuade
them without them thinking their dad's a
dog that's the issue you got to be
careful because they may think you talk
about money here and it you just said
they think this was their mom's dying
wish and you know you're going to get
now you're fighting with angels do you
want your kids thinking that you're
greedy
that's the risk no absolutely not I will
tell you I will tell you I think that's
the reason a little of the tail wagging
the dog here yeah I the only thing I
would probably do here is say listen if
you all don't want me to handle this for
you
because it was your mother's dying wish
I understand that I I really think it's
unwise for you to get 200 000 is 18
years old I'm your dad I love you and I
think it's gonna be a problem for you
rather than a blessing but I can't I I'm
not going to go back on my word if you
choose to give me this quarterback I
will protect you on it but if you don't
want to do that
um then I'm not gonna I'm not certainly
not going to force it I am going to do
my best as your dad to persuade you to
do smart things and not let this be a
problem for you but um but yeah it was a
um
uh you know it's horrible to say in this
situation but it's really dumb idea I
mean it's just uh but you're stuck with
it now and yeah you can't force this you
can't go in before the judge and go uh
your honor we want you to reverse this
because I really wasn't thinking clearly
that one won't work all right the judge
is going to go whoops sorry about that
stupid tax time so yeah hopefully you
can just persuade them uh that their
best interest is at heart and if you
can't then persuade them to do something
wise and let you help them help lead
them through good decisions with the
money but I think the money's probably
gone but it sounds like to me this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage in the studios it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love
create actual amazing relationships open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five my co-host today
Ken Coleman of the Ken Coleman show
author of the number one best-selling
book from paycheck to purpose
he is our Ramsay personality
specializing in jobs and careers you've
got questions along those lines we're
certainly here to help the phone number
eight eight two five five two two five
Mark is in Detroit hey Mark what's up
hey uh thanks for taking my call today
how you guys doing better than we
deserve sir how can we help good uh my
wife and I are 42 42 and 41 years old
and we've made it to baby step seven and
I'm calling with a question on what we
do as far as our intentional act uh for
our goal that we have for retirement
um we own everything that we have we
have zero debt zero credit cards and uh
I think about 350 000 in an investment
um portfolio at the bank
and my question is is our goal is to
purchase land in Eastern Tennessee and
build a house and retire there and about
seven to ten years and the question is
when do we pull that money out
to purchase it because I know land in
that side of the state goes up kind of
quick and Investments can raise too so
when do we pull that trigger is it
sooner rather than later or do we do it
right before we are ready to build and
move down there yeah I would do it right
before you move down there the Atlanta
land in East Tennessee isn't going up
any faster than anything or else that's
not I mean
I grew up I mean I was born there I grew
up in Tennessee I've been doing real
estate deals all over Tennessee and
including the mountains of East
Tennessee so no it's it's it's good it's
a good it's a good plan I love your plan
but it's not like you know you're going
to get priced out of the market or
something so what do you make
um so my wife and I our take home is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
excellent and yeah good for you so I'm
going to show you guys seven years to
pile up some cash what's the size of
this project do you think money-wise
um I'm guessing between purchasing the
land and building it that we're aiming
some probably where around 800 850 000
and our current home is worth 550 to
600. okay um and with the money that we
have in the bank and the money that we
can make uh between now and then when
we're returning the money now fine
if you sold your house you could go do
it now but you'd just not ready to do it
right now
yeah it's a matter of it's a matter of
uh I have seven and a half years to go
until I retire and when I retire I'll
have a pension for the rest of my life
in my life's life and yeah but my point
is the 550 000 house plus 350 000 in
Investment Portfolio today you've got
the money right
correct so I mean if you look at both
those boom we got it now you got no
money left after you did the deal but
you got the money so so you got seven
years to build your nest egg is what it
mounts to now your 350 000 invested at
the bank is that um in good growth stock
mutual funds
yes sir okay
and so if the money earns 10 percent
it will double every seven years
so that 350 will be 700.
okay oh by the way your 550 000 house is
going to be approaching a million
dollars by the time you get to seven
years
right okay so right there's a million
seven that's with adding nothing to what
you've already got and of course you're
going to add to it am I right
yes sir yeah we're we're expecting to
try and throw at least 60 000 at it
every year yeah so what I would do if I
were in your plan is I would enjoy the
adventure of this whole plan yeah and
that means I'm gonna uh in about three
years I'm gonna have a big old pile of
cash added to that 350. in some good
Investments and I'm going to spend a
year
poking around the hills of East
Tennessee figuring out where I want to
set up camp here
yeah we had that's where most of our
money has come from actually that uh we
had some real estate down there and then
we sold it
um when all you know when everybody
started moving to that to that area so
we sold it and then we've just invested
that money so
um we have an idea of where we want to
go and we've kind of been poking around
that area and actually sold it still but
the Adventure Continues then right yes
sir it's okay to go ahead and buy the
land as long as you're ready to pay cash
for it
sort of like a baby step slash yes ma'am
program so
um she is very much on uh purchasing
everything with cash no mortgages ever
again and I'm very much on board with
that so so what do you think you're
going to spend on the land
um well it kind of depends first we
started out with mountains and we were
thinking about a hundred thousand and
then uh then when she saw mountains with
a lake uh simply that budget got a
little bit higher so we're I'm gonna try
I think we're trying to limit ourselves
to no more than 150
. oh so you could buy the land whenever
you find it then
yes sir that's that's the question okay
but you don't have to buy it because
it's going to go up buy it now yeah I'm
just gonna I like I I like the art of
the deal I like hunting for Stuff
looking for a bargain finding the right
thing walking away from you you have abs
you have seven years to discover the
coolest property of all for 150 to 250
000 and write a check for it when you
find it
but there's no rush
yeah Mark I'm curious do you plan to
never work again or are you planning to
just take a couple years and see what
happens
uh so I'm probably gonna after seven
years uh my my kids will have three more
years of high school
um so I'll probably work until uh
they're all out of high school and then
to college and we're already putting
money away for them for college as well
so they can work from East Tennessee
uh yeah I couldn't mind it at all I I
figured I'd have to do something I can't
just well you probably ought to do
something anyway it's just good for you
yeah man it's not made to completely
retire and do nothing I I agree we'll
die trying to figure out and that's what
I'm working on now too is what do I do
when I retire well and the reason I ask
that question is because that brings in
some money to this equation that we
haven't talked about yet it's not like
you're going to completely go from from
what you're making now to zero so it
just it just furthers what Dave is
saying man just go enjoy it and find the
right place when you find it but you
don't need to go buy something now
because it's going to price you out
between now and seven years it's not
okay it's not and but I would enjoy the
process of looking for a good deal
on a killer piece of land with some Lake
Frontage or whatever it is you're
looking for there that would be neat I
wouldn't and there's some beautiful
stuff in the area you're talking about I
mean world class uh that's pretty
country it's beautiful country it really
is so yeah there you go that's what I
would do now that the cool thing about
this is that you're going to be fine
because you're actually doing it on
purpose
where people screw up with this kind of
stuff is when they just they wake up one
more and go oh God and then they just
yeah you know and they just have this
moment and then they go that's when you
go buy a Beach property that you should
have never bought land fever yeah you
just get this weird thing going and then
and then you wake up three months later
going I the guy in my mirror is an idiot
yeah that kind of stuff because he who
is impulsive exalts Folly mark on is the
opposite end of that he's super
intentional
planning way way out there
um yeah very very interesting very
interesting hey good call man good work
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions at AAA
825-5225 Jonathan in Idaho gives us our
question of the day
all right sorry Dave I was slow on the
draw here it is uh I was wondering if
you have an opinion on the proposed fair
tax act that would eliminate federal
taxes impose a national sales tax on new
Goods purchased and eliminate the IRS as
we know it that's the perfect question
for the two of us I don't know two
people that hate taxes more than me and
Dave Ramsey
um well I've always been a fan of this
in fact I lived for years in Atlanta and
Neil Bortz who was a well-known local
talk radio guy you're probably friends
with Neil I know well uh he was a big
proponent of this and and wrote another
show several times back in the day
talking about yeah best-selling book on
this very issue and I'm not going to
endorse the book nor am I going to
endorse the policy but I like the
direction that it's heading uh and I'll
tell you why
um I I think a sales tax uh it forces
the consumer to kind of deal with it and
it's not the federal government
mandating what is taken from my income I
like the flat tax idea which is really
the the guts of what Neil Brooks was was
kind of proposing and that's everybody
pays the same tax rate there's this
cultural divide now that the media uh
and a lot of people on the left have
created this fairness doctrine that the
person who makes more should have to pay
a higher percentage and it's become this
virtuous idea and in all reality if you
look at the actual data now folks some
of you are going to get offended right
now and that's okay but here's what I
want you to do while you're getting
offended I want you to actually go on
this thing called Google and I want you
to do your own research be brave enough
to research what I'm saying because
here's what you'll find
most people in America in fact it's
right below 50 I believe Now 51 51 Dave
corrects me don't pay any federal income
tax and yet we're going after wait a
minute and let's go step further yeah
sure and a large number of that group
not only don't pay right they receive
that's correct the unearned income tax
credit that's for meaning they get money
back from the government it's only it's
not back from the government because
they never gave it to him in the first
place it's an entitlement it's they are
given that's right their lives are
subsidized and and you're not you're not
evil if that's you okay we're not mad at
you about that that's the system that's
in place but 51 of Americans pay
absolutely nothing
yeah so this side in the federal income
tax program that that's not that's not
fair that's right so then they say not
only that's happening but now they want
to have people who are wealthy who help
create jobs by the way and help create
enough tax income for all of the
entitlements that those 51 percent get
you want to put more burden on this hook
so I love the flat tax that is kind of
the fair taxes or sales tax exactly
taxes I know but I I love the actual
flat tax on an income tax because I
think that that is truly Equitable and
everybody now is paying the same amount
and so you know the actual fair tax act
is not up for vote and I don't know the
way I don't know where you got this that
it's actually happening yeah it's not
it's not even close to happening it's a
it's a a a you know a discussion to try
to get people jacked up and it's been
going on for 20 plus years that book is
worth reading because the biggest gripe
that people have mathematically and it's
a fair argument
um it is that under a fair tax a uh an
ad valorem taxes national sales tax and
no income tax at all then you would have
to you would need to it would for it to
be correct I I for it to be Equitable
not fair or to be Equitable and bortz's
proposal the actual fair tax people are
proposing this you would have exemptions
on things like food yep because if you
make thirty thousand dollars a year and
you pay Inc or you pay sales tax on
everything you buy you end up paying a
larger percentage of your income in
taxes than say I would and that's not
Equitable correct okay uh I wouldn't
want a single mom making twenty thousand
to have uh you know have a a higher tax
rate than I do yeah that's not right and
so you have to have some exemptions in
there on income and on types of
purchases to make the thing start to
have some more Equity to it but the
beauty of it is you consume you you
choose that's correct now in the state
of Tennessee this is actually what we
have we have a moderately to high sales
tax nine and three quarter percent about
ten percent okay is our sales tax in the
state of Tennessee and uh we have zero
income tax and our economy is booming
yes because because people come here
like crazy that are producing things
like jobs and businesses and they come
here they're moving in here the same
thing with Texas same thing with Florida
the states that don't have an income tax
have prospered inordinately art Laffer
has written a lot about this that's
right and uh so it's a very interesting
discussion now you can get all pissed
off and lefty or righty about it one way
or the other if you want but that's you
know the you probably ought to just
listen to one of those political shows
to do all that stuff that that's not
political this is math right okay it is
not
Equitable not fair
for people to pay absolutely zero that's
correct whether they're rich or whether
they're poor and 51 percent of Americans
pay zero
income tax at the federal level
zero none
that's a half of you and it kind of
describes why the voting Falls where it
does
is actually the voting falls about that
way okay on national elections and so
you know and it you're right it has been
trumped up by the that's bad bad phrase
bad phrasing yes right it's been it's
been pushed by the uh the media because
they can sell hate that's correct and
you know make the poor people hate the
rich people the rich people hate the
poor people yeah all this kind of stuff
this class division thing and you know
if we can create Division and keep
people angry they'll keep watching our
news channel and that's not a good plan
so uh
I I mean I've spent a lot of time back
20 years ago I was on board the show
several times we discussed this it was a
very interesting discussion yeah it's
well thought out it's a good
intellectual exercise but Jonathan
here's the truth
it's not gonna happen right that's
that's the other side of it okay you're
not gonna get a fair tax a national
sales tax and do away with the IRS
your your lifts to God's ears that the
IRS went away but uh but they're not
going it's there's too much going on
here I mean here's the thing you put the
income tax business out of business
I mean you're talking about H R Block
TurboTax are gone gone oh yeah just poof
well all the entitled nothing to do all
those governments do you think they're
going to be for this no no yeah yeah the
entire establishment will never allow
this to happen the people could make it
happen but outside of that that's a
whole yeah just fire everybody it's a
whole difference up there which clearly
would be a great idea yeah but um yeah
it would be but you know it's
interesting you know because when you
start looking at this you got to
understand too that you we hear
inflation in the news every let's talk
about one of the most hot bed issues uh
hot button issues in America right now
is inflation but here's the deal if if
if if the people of America in Mass
let's say they got a hold of what we
teach here on the Ramsey Show and they
all started budgeting and they went to
the envelope system they used those
wallets and they did everything the way
we teach and they said you know what
we're going to severely cut back on all
of our excess spending okay four walls
that's it watch how prices would come
down Dave because these could the
targets
if Ramsay met the Millennials
minimalists yeah in the in the
marketplace yeah and all of America
adopted
for 90 days Dave I think 90 days it
would be like it'd be like putting
people on strike yeah and then
shut the freaking place down yeah you'd
get some uh Bozo's attention yeah I
gotta tell you I mean Bezos attention he
would put some dent in the inflation and
because but we spend like drunken
Sailors As Americans credit cards at all
times Sailors get a bad reputation
drunken Congressman that's a fair point
they spent a lot more that's true sorry
don't be messing with our Sailors both
my grandfathers were in the Navy I
should stipulate it isn't a great old
saying and I it it's more more
stereotypically true in the old days but
yeah there we go
oh so Jonathan sorry it's a good thing
to give us a little soapbox on here but
appreciate you asking the question not
gonna happen
um wouldn't make any of us mad if
something like this or something move
this direction where everybody everybody
ought to put something in the you know
everybody ought to put something in the
pot yo you ought to pay your military
that's right you ought to pay for your
interstates you're driving on everybody
ought to put something in this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
can guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Abby's with us hey Abby how are
you hey Dave and Kenneth good how are
you great how are you you look like
Happy Abby I'm super happy I Like It
where do you live I live in Indianapolis
Indiana awesomeness and how much debt
have you paid off Abby I paid off 51 511
cool how long did this take 29 months
good for you and your range of income
during that two and a half years um I
started out at 48 000 and with all the
other jobs up to 68 000. cool what do
you do for a living
um I was working as a cancer at a cancer
research organization as an
administrative officer but I just um
started my own business and went full
time in January uh I'm at pet care
professional oh cool cool making more
than you were yes absolutely good for
you so what kind of uh debt was the 52
um everything so student loans credit
cards a family loan medical debt a car
it's about kind of normal yeah pretty
much how old are you I'm 32. okay so
what happened when you're 30 years old
and you're looking around going this is
not working how did you get connected
with this Ramsay way so I first heard
about you for my sister
over here uh Rebecca she got her and her
family they got out of debt using your
program too and she told me about it and
she gave me your book for Christmas but
of course I didn't care too much I put
it in the closet um
no but she yeah she gave it to me and I
didn't really yeah I paid too much
attention to it but I did have every
dollar for a couple years I just didn't
really get into it but while you're
watching her
she was listening to it and I was just
like well yeah but you're watching her
succeed you knew she was doing good yes
yeah okay all right then what what
snapped
um so I think around covid um is it
thick of covet 2020 and August September
um I was already going through a really
difficult time like emotionally with
relationships and financially it was
really hard I would always look in my
bank account and see like negative 75
cents on a Tuesday and I don't get paid
till Thursday and no gas in the tank
um so that was like often
um something that happened to me and
then I would always have to like borrow
money from a friend my sister
she would like um and it was
embarrassing
um and like even like one time and I was
on a work trip and I was supposed to
um I arrived to the work trip I thought
the hotel was paid for
um I had kind of screwed up and didn't
have the hotel paid for so they asked
for my credit card card and I had no
money so I kind of had like a panic at
the mini panic attack in the hotel room
again had to borrow money for a short
time to get that paid off and it was one
of many of those things
um that happened and I just was sitting
in
um actually with a counselor at the time
and she was doing the same thing your
program to get out of debt he's
everywhere yeah
and I thought like maybe I'll just start
listening to like the Ramsey Show and
just see what happens and so I started
listening to it then
um and then I figured why don't I just
go and do Financial base so
um I started that I didn't know how to
get my first first thousand uh because
when I did my budget there was like over
budget even after I did like all the
minimum payments but somehow in the
first couple months I got my first
thousand and then I just started paying
off
um I got like an extra eight extra jobs
throughout the two years what was your
best extra job um money watch
I would say like probably either like
pet sitting or
chipped interesting now I gotta know did
that spark the interest to this new cell
phone business you entrepreneur you debt
free entrepreneur you and actually
thanks to you too yeah it was
um I've already always loved animals and
I've already been working with animals
for a long time and I had no idea how
I'd like be able to make money like
working for Animals because I would use
like the apps where they kind of take
part a portion of your pay
um if you're working so I started um I
figured out if I raise my prices I could
um start my own business and so I and
then Word of Mouth goes great yeah I
have a lot for you yeah that's
incredible very busy already
I'm telling you people Americans what
they'll spend on their pets is absurd
and you are the beneficiary of that good
for you yeah there's been moral known
than their kids
way to go way to go how's it feel to be
free ah it's so awesome it's definitely
a weight off my shoulder yeah well
you're smiling bro that's for sure I'm
so proud of you okay now you've been
through all this stuff you kind of
resisted for a while and then you went
all in
uh what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt-ish
um it's
definitely just like believe
you can do it because I didn't ever
think I could do it I've never saved
I've never had anybody in my bank
account like ever in my whole life and
now I do
um and like just waking up every day it
could be a good day whether it's a good
day or bad day just like
um the one thing that doesn't change is
like your goal to be debt free that
never changed for me
change your confidence overall didn't it
yeah it changed everything now that
you've got some money in the bank
because it means you are in control
there's some agency some idea that you
have the Dignity of your destiny in your
hands yeah and then you go open a
business and it's going to go yeah never
thought it would do that ever
that's so cool so proud of you thank you
very well done and I'm sure Rebecca is
yes they came down here to cheer you on
yeah right they're her own family yeah
very cool they should they should very
good well we're proud of you here way to
go absolutely well done Abby excellent
excellent job we've got the live and
give bundle for you to say thanks for
coming all the way down here from
Indianapolis to do your debt free scream
That's The Total Money Makeover book uh
and the baby steps millionaires book
that one's uh uh that's definitely your
path from here on and uh another
membership to Financial Peace University
you can give that to someone and help
them get started on their Journey
because I'm sure a couple people have
asked what happened that caused that big
smile because I bet it's different now
yes
well done very very well done Abby from
Indianapolis 52
000 dollars paid off in 29 months making
48 to 68. most importantly though lands
in her own new business and that just as
this is how America works I love it
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one I'm dead
yeah that's right there
oh man beautiful job
absolutely fabulous fabulous
that she's inspiring oh completely now
she goes from victim her whole life
financially to now she's a Victor she's
in total charge got an incredible future
doing something she loves it's
unbelievable well no it's not true it's
very believable we see this all the time
yeah and you've been seeing these career
breakthroughs like this on your show
everywhere now we're going to take it on
the road we got the career breakthrough
events in Kansas City April the 20th
Chicago May 16th at Atlanta Georgia May
18th in Dallas Texas May 23rd with Ken
Coleman what are you gonna be talking
about I'm gonna be talking about the
formula to make sure you break through
what's been holding you back
professionally and financially Dave you
said for decades that your income is
your greatest wealth building tool and
we also know that everybody longs to
make their Mark in this world so we're
gonna be talking about Clarity
confidence and courage they're not a
mystery that's a formula because if you
want to break through even Financial in
your life you've got to have Clarity
which will give you confidence to step
out and urge to stay on the path and
then because you know what Abby did
that's exactly what she did she she saw
a plane not only in her starting her
business but in getting out of debt so
the baby steps are a clear path getting
clear what's the problem what's the
solution that she got clear and then she
got to around people a financial peace
and that's where the confidence comes in
that she can do it and then she stayed
with it so uh it's going to be a fun
event Dave these are uh these are really
fun and intimate theaters I'm going to
be taking questions live from the crowd
after speaking and sharing that formula
so that people can walk away with
absolute confidence to do what they were
created to do and here's the benefit of
that more money and more meaning
that's what we're gonna give people is
the the ability to get over Dave you
hear this all the time imposter syndrome
fear of failure I got an idea which is
the best idea that's what we're going to
be addressing people that want to get
ahead financially and professionally
career breakthrough events are going to
be small intimate events where you're
able to take questions and deal with it
and help people all the way through
you're going to get a get clear
assessment as part of your 50 ticket and
they're going to be Kansas City Chicago
Atlanta Dallas all in April and May to
get your tickets go to
ramseysolutions.com
events don't miss it Ken is coming to a
city near you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today this is the Ramsay show common
sense for your life and your dollars and
cents open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Charlotte's
in Burlington Vermont hi Charlotte how
are you
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
yeah
um well first of all I just kind of want
to preface with a lot of this stuff is
new to me
um I've kind of just been a big favor
most of my life so now I'm kind of
learning a lot more from you and other
people in my life about just handling my
money better so cool
um yeah I am kind of at a place where
like I said I had cured like 45 000 in
my savings and it's my parents and other
people are like you've got to kind of do
something with that money
um I am debt free so there's not
um not going on anymore uh but I yeah I
basically have set up a Vanguard account
and I don't have retirement through my
job so I put like 12 000 in a Roth IRA
but then I have that remaining
um like 23 000 and it's kind of one of
those things where I'm not really sure
what to do with it
um I I don't like I said it's not in my
savings anymore I want to be investing
in and doing something with that money
but I'm not necessarily sure what
direction to go in I don't have like an
immediate goals like oh I want to buy a
house at this point you know
um so I just kind of want to be wise and
planning for the future but doing
something with that money now gotcha
okay well you're doing great by the way
you're in the top three or four percent
of Americans because you actually save
money which makes you very very weird in
a good way okay so um that's very cool
good job all right so the first thing we
teach people to save for is for
emergencies
and you should have some of this money
set aside in a simple money market
account just for emergencies and the
amount is three to six months of
household expenses what's it take you to
operate if you had no income for three
months and six months and somewhere
between there would be the amount do you
have any money earmarked for emergencies
now
I do I have about like twelve thousand
set aside and what do you make yeah
I made forty four thousand a year that's
probably pretty close Okay so if you
want to put a little bit more in it
wouldn't hurt anything but twelve
fifteen thousand dollars is probably
going to be in really nice emergency
fund and you never touch that
except for emergencies
right once you label that account the
emergency fund you can't use that money
unless it's an emergency
okay and I want a new car it's not an
emergency
I want to go on a trip is not an
emergency you following me
yes okay so we've got that money labeled
and it's kind of just sits there doesn't
do anything it's your insurance policy
against life bringing you crap okay yeah
now then once you've got that then the
second thing you save for is you save
for purchases
and so if you're going to move up in car
you're going to buy a couch you're going
to go on a vacation you're going to save
up and pay for that and I would do that
on a separate account so it doesn't get
mixed up with emergencies and uh it
doesn't sound like you've got anything
on the horizon so if you don't have that
account today that's okay and then that
leaves you how much money
um yes I have 23 000 left to do
something with and you put that in a
Vanguard account you said what type of
Vanguard S P 500
um it's an individual brokerage right
now okay all right
all right I would personally just park
it in s p 500. it's going to do whatever
the stock market does it's not a lot of
risk okay
it's not super uh it's just going to do
whatever the market does so the market
does good it's going to do good and I've
got a bunch of my personal money sitting
in that right now S P 500 fund and and
because later on you're going to use
that probably for a house in the future
would you agree right right yeah that's
kind of kind of my like longer term goal
but
but today we're not ready to do that so
we'll just label that future house fund
so the good thing what I'm teaching you
to do here is the little bit of fine
tuning to your already good ideas is
just labeling these savings accounts
yeah yeah and then you need to get your
Roth IRAs going and have that be part of
your budget
that you just automatically each month
have it drafted out of your checking
account into a good growth stock mutual
fund for your Roth IRAs if you don't
have an easy way to do that click
ramseysolutions.com click on Smart
investor and you'll find one of the
people in the investment world that we
endorse in your area that we recommend
they'll have the heart of a teacher and
they'll sit down with you and help you
decide what's best for you in this
situation and probably get those that
other in Roth IRA that you've already
done moved over there as well and get it
all moving but you're really really
really doing a good job yeah I love what
you just shared with her because here's
someone who's already figured out
savings now we put some strategy to it
by being specific and so she's got the
discipline part and she's going to win
big because of what you just laid out
because now she goes oh there's a
strategy not just saving in general but
saving specifically yeah here's what's
weird a natural saver like her someone
who saves just because they love saving
money and certain people my wife's that
way a natural shaver like her will not
keep up with
a and a person who does intentional
investing and labeling of the accounts
that's right even though they have a
more natural strength in the area they
will not end up with as much money
because they they get their uh release
from just having saved even though they
did it poorly right and so somebody
pushed her to become an investor not
just a saver yeah that's the difference
saving is you're loaning money to the
bank investing is you're becoming an
owner of something that's right and that
changes the whole equation when you do
that Jason is in Salt Lake City hey
Jason welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you how are you guys doing better
than we deserve what's up
it's where we just just have our student
loans and our mortgage
um and we're trying to decide if we
should sell our house to pay off our
student loans or if we should try and
figure out a way to uh pay off our
student loans
um with the interest and everything
starting up man that's sad
I'm sorry you're facing that how much
student loan debt have you gotten
190 96 000
ouch who's the doctor or the lawyer
uh my wife's a speech pathologist and I
do physical therapy
household income over 200 then
no not right now um it's right around
120 our life's working part-time with
four children
and so I had three from a previous
marriage and we have one of our own as
well and for daycare for all of them
it's about four thousand dollars a month
if we were to put them in daycare so
she's working part-time and I'm
currently working full-time and we're
looking at maybe doing some other side
hustle stuff here shortly best side
hustle things she could do is more
Speech Pathology
it pays unbelievably good pays better
than yours does
as a side hustle so yeah anything we can
do to get her doing more of that even if
she's doing it at somehow working from
home as individual clients or something
while the kids are napping anything you
can do like that is get your income up
is going to be a good thing
um right so the only reason I would sell
your home is if I had lost hope that I
could knock out the student loans in a
reasonable period of Time how old are
the kiddos what's your age range
um they're ages six months to eight
years old
okay
so I mean you got a long four years in
front of you
yes I mean when the youngest gets to
kindergarten she could kick it in a lot
harder right
right and uh until then you're going to
be doing this on 100 to 150 a year with
four kiddos little ones to boot
um and you know if you did 50 000 a year
for four years you'd be done right
yes that but that'd be hard the interest
rate with it with our interest rate
starting back up it's over a thousand
dollars a month in interest on our first
student loans yeah yeah that's true one
quick thing I want to challenge you
that's a whole twelve thousand dollars a
year that's not going to be your problem
your problem is uh getting enough cash
flow to throw at this as fast as you can
which to that end Jason really quick
challenge
my wife went back to work for a season
we had three kids they needed you know
some care and if you're connected in
your community I'd be looking for an
elderly grandmother who's still healthy
and loves kids who's just looking for
some side money you got to see how can
we cut from four thousand dollars or
almost five thousand a month on daycare
to maybe 12 1500 that's a way to allow
your wife to work more and cut your
costs yeah Gotta Get Crazy Innovative
right now yeah you both took out
expensive
degrees in areas where you both have the
ability to make north of a hundred
thousand but it's going to obviously
require working to do that so you can
clean up the mess but it's going to be
you got to get shovels you gotta get
shovels and that's what we're trying to
help you figure out I'm not trying to
put her to work I'm just trying to get
out get you out of debt without selling
your house I'd sell your house as a last
resort to answer your question and I
don't think you're there yet this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for being with us America the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality host of the Ken Coleman show
and author of the number one
best-selling book paycheck to purpose is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Donna starting off this hour Baltimore
Maryland hey Donna how are you
I'm fine thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
so I am looking at retiring within five
years but I want to get my dream card
before I retire and I hope to have it
this year so I'm calling because with my
financial profile I want to know what
would you do if you were in my shoes
okay what's your name what is your net
worth how much of an estate do you have
well
I'm single
single under thirty three thousand
I do have a home but I have a mortgage
that is about 97 000 is left on it
what's it worth
about
275. okay all right so you got a net
worth of about 750 000 dollars
and you have any money other than that
not really I just have my emergency fund
okay and what is what's a dream car cost
the dream car is a used car and I'm
budgeting
thousand
s so it would be maybe a Lexus or a
Volvo or maybe a Genesis if I could find
one within my price range I like it and
what do you make
um my gross amount is 163 my take home
is 93 and I I guess that's about 7 200
um each month
okay what have you got coming out of
your check I know I seem to have a lot I
looked at that too and it was like great
day in the morning I mean I have my
medical insurance my my dental I have my
um retirement money that comes out
Vision
um and I just I'm single and I I pay a
lot in taxes so yeah we don't pay that
much of taxes but okay all right wow
good for you uh well whenever you can
pay cash for it I would buy it
so Dave here's the thing here it comes
with my plan because I can take money
from my retirement without being
penalized for it I was and and the goal
is I would what I would like to do but
if it if but I don't have to I'm just
telling you in my heart what I would
like to do I would like to buy this car
maybe this year or next year at
62.63 so that I can have some years of
driving it well you're like 20.
I mean years uh so um
20 years you make 163 000 yeah I mean
you're probably driving to your 80. I
hope so I do too
um or you'll be gone well I mean there's
there's a lot of choices here but yeah
um
so I mean
I just bought a truck and I never
dreamed it would be the last truck I
would ever buy I never thought about it
I'm 62 also so I just don't think that
way but the uh
uh uh too much drama on this car
purchase but yeah I I don't know why you
can't save up forty thousand dollars
making 160 Grand
like in a year in a year either but my
numbers went oh I'm sorry in a year in a
year one year in one year yes 40 000 out
of 160.
now I'm also trying to pay down my house
so I'm also taking a lot of that
take-home money and throwing it at my
mortgage
also
I said oh money's finite thing it's
going to go one place or the other
right so if you want to slow down the
paying of your house I would do that
before I would pull money from
retirement
okay yes but I do once you get your
house paid off I don't want you to buy
this car and I want you to keep money
putting money in retirement I'd love the
house to be done before you retire
and buy that and buy the car yeah
three except for yep yeah your house
your house is debt free and you've got
you know 550 that turns into 700 or
whatever uh and you got a paid for car
and your emergency funds in place that's
what we call being set up for retirement
you did a great job then but you need to
try to lay out the numbers I don't care
which order we do it in let's pay off
the house and then buy the car or buy
the car and then pay off the house but I
would not drain retirement to do it I
don't think you need to here I think
you've got a fabulous income Donna and
you got a lot of options yeah and she's
been disciplined you know so far so far
and now all of a sudden I gotta have
this car right now you know and you know
what they think about the thing about
the car is that it'll be very exciting
for her for about a month
and then you pretty much adapt pretty
quickly that's just how we humans are it
kind of wears off no matter how awesome
it is doesn't mean you don't appreciate
it doesn't mean you're not grateful for
it but the buzz that she's feeling right
now the pull it's gonna wear off pretty
quick yeah and then you know it's a car
it just I mean maybe a thirty thousand
dollar car you know why does it got to
be 40. there you go and then move up
later in car
buy 30 and then buy 50 later like after
you retire I mean if the goal is to pay
off a house then I wouldn't stop that
much I wouldn't slow down very much on
that you know cars are interesting
emotionally yeah oh because they're a
large physical item
and um we tend to think when we buy one
that it's going to be around longer than
it is
it's it has it has because it's large it
takes up space it it feels emotionally
like it's gonna be around
and we really go through more cars than
most of us think oh sure she's she's the
way she's talking about this she's going
to have it for 20 years
you know and probably not really
probably not
I mean you know a 20 year old if you're
got a million dollar net worth you know
a 20 year old SUV he's probably not what
you're driving right well just to be
real
Alexis SUV at 40 000 Still's got a good
chunk of miles on it you know it's not a
it's not a low mile product those SUVs
are expensive no yeah so the rumor yeah
yeah right so it's which is crazy well I
mean it's fine but but it's interesting
it's you
we assign the type of permanence to a
car purchase that we assign emotionally
that we assigned to buying a house and
it's just not the same no you can jump
in and out of cars you don't want to but
I mean if she bought that my point is
three years from now she could easily
upgrade so you're right by 25. yeah it's
probably a sizeable upgrade form and
then move to a 50. that's correct you
know uh three years from now after the
house has paid off and you're 65 and
because it's not like you are you know
you can buy a car at 65 and never buy
another car again in your life you can
do it but um you know as long as your
health holds out and your ability to
drive holds out it's not likely you're
likely going to upgrade change to do
something it's we how long do people
generally keep a car in America not that
long really it will fool you I'm gonna
drive until the wheels fall off yeah it
says everybody and Nobody Does it that's
true it just doesn't happen very often
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
a lot of folks have questions about
taxes right now we get that
here's a question from one of our
listeners what's the difference between
an itemized deduction and the standard
deduction
well the standard deduction is a set
amount that you can subtract from your
taxable income
it's like your automatic text freebie
the amount you can deduct based on your
filing status let's say you're single
you make seventy thousand your standard
deduction knocks off thirteen thousand
dollars so you only pay taxes on about
fifty seven thousand dollars
an itemized deduction is one of the
specific expenses the IRS allows you to
deduct to deduct from your taxable
income when it's time to file your taxes
stuff like charitable giving your home
interest that kind of thing
and so in the example of the guy above
if uh if you're giving and your itemized
deductions you're giving your home
interest doesn't exceed 13 000 then you
would not do itemized you would just
take the standard deduction because you
get more Sac saving you get more savings
on your taxes than you can actually
write off with the standard deduction
that's given to you before you do
anything else that that's the way this
thing works now here's what's
interesting they raised the standard
deduction considerably it's up to 27 7
for a married couple
you don't pay taxes on twenty seven
thousand dollars
okay
um to the point that you've got to have
very serious itemized deductions that
was raised on the Trump Administration
you have to have very very serious
itemized deductions to even bother with
doing an itemized filing and
consequently only 13 percent of
Americans last year did itemized 87 did
standard
so let me help you with another part of
that then this interesting the idea I'm
going to keep my home mortgage because
of the tax deduction doesn't apply
unless you don't take the standard
deduction
so and 87 don't so people saying they're
going to keep their home mortgage for
the tax savings is uh mathematically a
bunch of crap because most of you aren't
87 percent of you are not writing off
your home mortgage you're taking
standard deduction and so that's just
Malarkey so that's just kind of how the
tax thing works there most people are
going to take the center deduction again
87 doing the reason is a married couple
would be as high as 27-7
single 13 000 some change there you go
so for more tax tips and software that
can help you file with confidence go to
ramseysolutions.com smart tax
Ramsey smart tax guides you through the
online filing process with low upfront
pricing no hidden fees and we're not
going to try to sell you a credit card
like they do at Turbo Tax so just want
to be real clear about that
ramseysolutions.com smart tax Lee is in
Denver hey Lee what's up
all right so so my question is
how do you
[Music]
hear professional financial disaster
it's like I get through stuff one and
start working on step two and then
something comes up and step one is
totally back to zero
okay
sounds like a lot of drama
um
Perpetual financial disaster is not one
I've ever heard that's interesting so uh
you've you just had you you you can't
seem to get ahead because you get keep
getting kicked off the ladder is that
what you're saying
yeah so what happened give me like two
or three of the examples
Okay so
like in November my boyfriend broke up
with me and moved out and I was stuck
paying for
um the place I live by myself which is
1600 a month have you moved and then uh
no and the reason I'm not moving is I
did find a roommate but my landlord
actually really likes me as a tenant and
said that he would drop my rent two
hundred dollars if I signed another
lease come May
what do you make
um so last year I made about 60 000
right now it's looking like way less
than that because I started a new job
um pursuit of a career instead of a dead
end job okay this is not a Perpetual
financial disaster this is Perpetual bad
decisions
yeah I mean the other thing that is
really
um
causing a financial disaster is I got a
car a year and a half ago I've been
working on paying it off because it does
have high interest on it and it got
stolen two weeks ago so it took away
praise God that I have insurance
um
I did yeah you got out of the high
interest rate
they're going to pay it off right
no so I'm upside down in the car and
because of how essential my car is
um they're not totaling it they're
working a lot of damage they found at
the next day so I'm still stuck with the
car
um
and what I do with it is I mean I travel
for my I am in healthcare I do sleep
studies but I also drive for Uber on the
side to kind of supplement what I'm
making in healthcare
so how much do you own This Disaster of
a car
and how much are they going to give you
for the damage
um 13 I think
about 3 500 is the damage estimate on it
so not enough to Total out the car
okay
what's your interest rate
[Music]
.
so I again I'll repeat myself you have
not had Perpetual financial disasters
you've had Perpetual bad decisions
okay 21 is in the stupid Zone signing up
for a lease you can't afford with your
live-in boyfriend who takes office in
the stupid Zone
you set yourself up for these things
these weren't things that happened to
you you caused them
okay so that if you want to stop having
them then that's the that's the way to
fix it is we've got to start thinking
with a clearer head so what you what if
I woke up in your shoes what I'm gonna
do is put 3500 on this car and I'm gonna
work day and night night and day have
absolutely no life until I get this car
paid off and I'm going to move out of
this stupid apartment you can't afford
with a roommate that isn't going to pay
that's your next bad decision and get
you something very very cheap that you
can afford because if you had a lower
rent and no car payment and you work
like a crazy person you could have some
money
[Music]
and to that end I'd stop doing the Uber
because you're just you're putting more
miles on your car you can find other
hourly jobs right now that can pay
better than Uber and allow you to stock
up more money and not be causing you
know damage to the car and all of the
gas money you can do better on that
second third job like give an example
Ken well Target at 20 bucks an hour so
yeah take take a big box store like a
Walmart or Target you should look at 17
to 20 bucks an hour you know and you're
pulling extra hours and work all the
time
as a waitress let me tell you
restaurants are dying to find people you
go in a good high-end right a good nice
restaurant we're going to get good tips
yep I mean you're making more of your
time you're not driving that car I want
you working so much you are freaking
exhausted and you have no time to party
right
yeah and I was doing that last year
um I was doing 80 hours a week in
security and then security didn't pay
anything to another
well yeah I was making I think 18 hours
during security much better than I
thought okay good
well you've done it before you can do it
again but this is going to be a shorter
time span and you're coming out on the
other side debt free and walking the
baby steps and now you've got Financial
Freedom I mean you should not ever have
a boyfriend leave and leave you an alert
ever again no because you've already
done that one once you're gonna have to
do that one again uh you should not ever
sign up for a 21 interest rate on a car
ever again you've already done that once
you never have to do that one again see
my goal when I was young Lee I did a lot
of really stupid things that's how I can
recognize this I mean I got a PhD in
Dumb I've done every stupid thing you
can do but my goal was to never do the
same stupid thing twice
and so once you've got a whole bunch of
stupid things on your resume already and
you never do them again you start to
become what they call Wise because all
the stupid stuff's more in your rear
view mirror that's what happened to me
yeah and here's what we know people ask
my advice I know amazing but you know
here's the deal you will change when
your pain forces you to or your desired
future inspires you to and I think in
this case you got to take both of those
the pain and the desired future for a
better life and put them together and
get after it bust it once you're going
crazy yeah making a lot of money and
doing nothing to spend it clear this car
up get out of that lease get you a place
where I know your landlord likes you I
bet he likes you that's yeah I bet he
does
they most landlords are good no he wants
to do her a favor for her to sign a
longer lease yeah he's such a nice guy
I'm gonna help you out here yeah uh nope
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
salute
free stage Patrice is with us hi Patrice
how are you hey Dave good to have you
where do you live Long Island New York
well welcome to Nashville all the way
here to do a debt free scream and how
much have you paid off 76 000. all right
how long did this take you two years and
four months look at you way to go kiddo
and your range of income during that
time uh about forty thousand and my best
year during that time was 80 000 with
overtime cool what do you do for a
living USPS letter carrier all right so
you get a lot of OT with that huh a lot
of OTP people don't want to come to work
Dave they didn't want to come in so you
pick up the extra route yes okay because
you got the T-shirt says if you're broke
go to work exactly especially when it
rains people don't come to work when it
rains I don't even like it in the rain
now that's like a USPS thing you're
supposed to deliver the mail in the Rain
the sleet the snow I mean whatever right
yeah you would think you would think but
that gives you opportunity absolutely
you can do whatever you want to do pick
up so what's it pay at OT an hour
um after eight hours you get time and a
half so my rate is twenty three dollars
my base rate so 34.50 yeah after eight
hours I mean after 10 hours you get
double time so forty six dollars yeah
you're reaching for that I like it how
many hours were you working in a given
week uh anywhere from minimum 60 to even
72 hours wow sometimes 10 days in a row
breaking all type of labor laws just
just working I'm all for some Civil
Disobedience that's great I talk about
hustle and grind you get after it yeah
it's there what kind of what kind of
debt was this 76 000 all student loans
okay what's your degree in sociology
okay I don't use it and so now you're a
letter carrier okay and you're making
money I'm proud of you way to go how'd
you get connected up this Ramsay stuff
uh actually I was doing some work at my
uncle's house and I was like dude how do
you have this house in Long Island like
you know taxes is crazy and he goes
I was Davis and he hands me the book
Total Money Makeover and he showed me
the YouTube videos and I was just hooked
since and I listened to you every day
when I'm on the route you and John can
and it keeps me going wow wow that's
right I'll be thinking about that next
time I'm on the microphone here hello
somewhere there's a letter carrier in
Long Island yeah I like it I like it way
to go yeah very very cool
where did you go to school I'm sitting
here and I'm going a sociology degree
and 76 000 is two months I'm just
curious I started off at Nassau
community and I transferred I was there
for four years so it was there pretty
long and then I transferred to City
College and uh I wanted to live closer
to the campus so the apartments there in
New York City are pretty pretty
expensive so I took out uh the maximum
ten thousand oh per semester and um I
actually didn't start paying off I
graduated in 2012. I didn't pay off
until
recently so all that time all that
they're just just laying there building
up yeah it's just a true penalty yeah it
really is that and good for you you just
said I'm over it yeah and if it wasn't
for you guys I probably would still have
that debt because where I live in my
family just people have debt so it
really was normal it's kind of like
everywhere yeah yeah it's normal
everywhere not just with you but way to
go what are you dreaming about because
you can do anything man you got you got
yeah enough girl I I wanna I wanna get
into real estate too but like you preach
yeah you have to cash flow and then I
listen to people at my job and they buy
stuff on credit they drive around BMWs
and
but I definitely um I dream just to be a
homeowner and be a babysat millionaire
um I think you're on my way one more
thing I want to add that with the post
office they have a tsp which is yeah
which is really good and um I'm doing 15
right now and I got the Roth tsp now too
yeah yeah drop it in that c plan yeah I
like it CNS I did pretty good last month
yeah
yeah that's awesome and people let my
job say well I got kids and you know I
can't put that much in them like well
stop going they order lunch and I order
you know I bring my lunch to work
you know they'll go out and order food
you were eating in the car a lot or yeah
I always bring my lunch they call me the
cheapest one in the office but no you're
the richest one too yeah you're the debt
free one yeah for sure everything's paid
off 100 how does it feel to be free that
feels great I get to come to the Dave
Ramsey Show on a random Tuesday
yeah I could do whatever I want
basically yeah yeah you got you got you
got choices now that's what it gives you
and you can choose a different career
you can choose to make the bet most of
this career you can choose a lot of
different things and yeah you know
what's interesting about your story is
is that um
you took power you you you walked out of
this very powerfully you have a lot of
power now that you didn't have yeah Dr
Johnson doesn't believe in you right
yeah he talks about um Carry On These
book bag um bricks in your book bag and
um it definitely felt like that you know
you walk around life and you're like I
got all this dead I'm gonna and you're
just going through life but now it's
like I I owned I put the book back down
you know I own my life now and I could
do whatever I want you know I don't even
have to work for the Post Office 10 more
years you know once I get my um 401K up
you know I plan on maybe buying a
laundromat or something I don't know all
these thoughts come in my head but I
could do whatever I want now now and you
know how to do it now yeah and by the
way Dave the dreams will continue to
flood through your head because now
there's no limits yeah so people that
are in debt have a hard time dreaming
and and there's no telling what's going
to come out of that that head and heart
of yours and you're gonna do something
Pro incredible stuff you really are this
one's special
there's a work ethic there's a Swagger
yeah you're going somewhere you said
Dave there's money out there he's got to
go get it it's America man
I literally have Goosebumps right now
say it again from the back if I can do
it I started that when I started working
at the post office I wasn't even a
career employee meaning I didn't have
any benefits I was making 17 an hour but
with the hard work and overtime man I I
was able to make way more than that so
anybody out there listening you guys can
do it no matter what you're doing no
matter how little money you're making
per hour I paid off seventy six thousand
dollars and the way I was able to do
that was I actually broke it up into 10
000 markers so every ten thousand
dollars I in my head I was like all
right I'm one step closer and to be
honest the last probably like seven
thousand was the hardest because they're
right there but you know but yeah yeah
it's harder to finish it off yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt ish you're why you
have to have a reason at the end what's
yours mine was to get a house to be a
homeowner
good dream yeah and and like your uncle
huh yeah exactly how'd you get this
house read this book I like it very cool
thank you Dave you're amazing you're
amazing I'm so proud of you I'm honored
to get to meet you very very cool I
gotta I I have a an easy prediction to
make this one's Gonna Leave awake oh no
question about it so impressive good
stuff good stuff hey we got the live and
give bundle for you that's the baby
steps millionaires book uh the
prediction of your future and uh The
Total Money Makeover book to give away
to someone that uh you run into like you
a few years ago very cool and uh
Financial Peace University if you've not
done it yet you should do it if you have
uh then give it to somebody and Pay It
Forward here and help people get moving
so I'm so proud of you very very very
well done you're amazing let me ask you
this who was your biggest cheerleader
uncle
honestly the podcast like I said I
listen to it I listen to it every every
day on my route listening and it's what
kept me going because a lot of people
don't understand when you tell them they
they just and what do you mean yeah they
don't what do you mean just put it on a
credit card yeah when you're when your
broke friends are making fun of your
financial plan you know you're right on
track huh yeah good stuff Patrice you're
amazing well done Patrice from Long
Island 76 000 paid off in in two years
in four months making 40 to 80 with some
serious OT counted down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one I'm debt
free yeah
yeah wow
[Applause]
some master class and momentum you know
she said all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
tackle the first ten believing you can
yeah and just getting after it believing
you can and then doing it oh man it's
just powerful it really is powerful
makes us glad we're here on these
microphones every day so true you know
I'm sitting here thinking for a second
everybody wants to drive Uber and I'm
not knocking Uber at all but here we're
talking about a postal third you're
making forty dollars an hour at certain
points when she's double time ding ding
come on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today James 3 13 who is
wise and understanding among you let
them show it by their Good Life by Deeds
Done in the humility that comes from
wisdom
Samuel Coolidge said common sense in an
uncommon degree is what the world calls
wisdom ooh I like it open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host today Drew is in Atlanta hi
Drew welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey Ken hey what's up
I'm just
Financial advice
um
I'm willing to buy a house but I'm also
trying to plan for retirement you know I
want to be a millionaire and I retire
like everybody else but um
I have about um 260 000 saved up in cash
um I don't have any debt my car is paid
for but it is about 10 years old
um still runs fine but I know I need
another one in your future probably but
um
just kind of trying to figure out uh
should I throw all of my money or most
of it at a house to try to buy it in
cash or should I take some of it to try
to start investing because right now as
far as Retirement goes all I have is my
401k it's got about a hundred thousand
dollars in it how old are you trying to
try to
36 sir man you're doing great
congratulations where'd you get 250
thousand dollars
um
um I just save a lot try to live on a
little you know you're single
yes sir what's your income
um
before taxes it's probably like seventy
thousand anywhere from 65 to 70 000
depending
um that's before taxes and 401k and
everything comes out you're just a
savings maniac
I love it way to go man you've done
great I'm proud of you excellent job
what do you do for a living
I'm a nuclear medicine technologist
what's your what's the what's the I'm
just curious what's the ladder look like
for you financially what does it look
above you what does it look like above
you
um there's no real ladder it's just you
know occasional raises they're pretty
small raises but okay all right I hadn't
heard that title before that's uh sounds
very impressive okay good for only 14
000 of us in the country so it's not
extremely common okay okay excellent
well
um what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes and I had a hundred thousand in my
401k I'm 36 years old I make seventy
thousand I got 250 260 000 in the bank
um I would set aside an emergency fund
out of that of three to six months of
expenses and I would buy a house
the rest of it in the house yeah all of
it and uh then and then I would if you
if that doesn't buy the house with cash
which it might not in Atlanta okay
then you know you finish paying off the
houses your next big goal and as soon
while you're putting 15 of your income
away towards retirement and
um into good in you know into your 401k
into good growth stock mutual funds Roth
401k preferable
um
and you know you keep doing that baby
step four fifteen percent of your income
into the four types of mutual funds
we're talking about all around here all
the time and
[Music]
um
get the if you take out a little bit
let's say you took out a uh
put down uh uh 240
000 and uh you took out a sixty thousand
dollar loan and you got a 300 000 house
right and you pay that off and just and
you pay that off very very quickly and
then once you've done that then you're
headed towards being a millionaire very
quickly because you got the real estate
going up in value and now you're going
to load up your 401k and your Roth IRAs
and do your longer term investing until
you get to that million but that's going
to put you there in probably five years
about five years yeah okay that's about
how far out should I look at I'm sorry
that's okay go ahead
um yeah look at investing any money now
through like uh a firm like Edward Jones
or something not not Beyond 15 percent
15 of your income going into 401k if
you're going to take out a small
mortgage your next goal is put it all on
the mortgage
okay until your house is paid off when
that's paid off then get with a smart
investor pro at ramseysolutions.com find
somebody to help you do investing and
you do your Roth IRAs and you Max those
out and you max out everything you can
put over at work not just 15
um and you know then we figure out what
we're going to do beyond that if you
want to do even more because you're just
you just love saving money but that
that's where I would start and that's
going to get you there very very very
quickly you're going to be amazed
because you know seven years from today
you if you're doing all of that you're
gonna have three or four hundred
thousand dollars saved in just your
retirement alone and you're gonna have a
paid for you know four or five hundred
thousand dollar house at that point yeah
and I would also say your saver so start
saving now to replace that car you know
because it's it's you said it's running
fine but it's it's older and it's
putting on some age so again plan for
that and you're gonna be great Kevin is
in Denver Hey Kevin how are you
good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
hey uh so I'm having some issues uh kind
of budgeting with my career I just
started a new uh career about two years
ago started my own business and it's
peaking in the summer times and it's
pretty dead in the winter times
um so I picked up a second job in the
winter to help kind of pay for things
but I'm having some issues with my work
man it's my only vehicle and they say it
needs a whole new engine in it so
they're quoting me about 5 000 for that
which is a lot more than the van is
worth so kind of trying to see how to
get around that without uh taking out a
loan to get a new vehicle
now take it you have no money
yeah uh I don't have too much debt about
twenty three thousand dollars in debt uh
on what we have about
uh well I owe ten thousand to my aunt
she helped me pay for uh my farrier
school it's the career I started the new
trade that I started um she helped me
pay for that so I owe her money for that
and then all about 5 000 from student
loans that I used to have uh when I went
to college for the year that I went
um and then the rest is uh credit cards
only about three thousand
okay and what are you in what are you
doing at your side job
uh deliver packages for Amazon
what's that pay
about twenty dollars an hour 2075
and you use your car
uh no I use their Advance okay all right
and you have absolutely no money
uh probably have a thousand dollars okay
all right I'd sell your van as is
and uh take the the money with that and
put the thousand dollars with it and get
me a little car to get around for right
now and then I would work like a crazy
person this winter to put together the
money to buy a five thousand dollar van
by Spring
okay and then let's get this debt paid
off and start working through your debts
from there uh but I want you working
like all the time
yes sir like all the time three hours on
Amazon right now and then I do uh horses
in the morning when I have time on the
weekends 30 hours
40 hours
oh we need to do a lot more than that
yes sir you need to be gone all the time
you're broke man for sure for sure for
sure you need some money and I don't
know where to get money except from work
yeah what are you making in the farrier
business
uh last year I didn't have a second job
I made it just under 40 000.
um probably most of that is during the
summer months uh probably get around six
to seven thousand yeah so if you made 40
in the winter working like your tail off
in 40 in the summer that's 80 000 income
right
and and you can get this deck cleaned up
with that and get a cash fan for five
thousand dollars but yeah I don't I mean
you don't need a fancy van you because
you're going to beat the snot out of it
anyway
yeah that's why I got a 2006 Chevy uh
yeah cargo van right now and I already
had 170 000 miles so that thing's going
to bring that thing's gonna bring a
thousand bucks like it sits or maybe
1500 like it sits with no engine in it
and it's Salvage and you put your
thousand with it you buy 2500 car to get
you through the winner just to get back
and forth to Amazon's all you got to do
because you're going to be working all
the time
yep and I still have a private clients
for horses uh in the winter time too so
that's kind of the issue with just a car
yeah okay we're gonna get a really junky
two thousand dollar van instead of a car
gotcha but pay cash for it no payments
you don't need any more payments you got
enough payments
no no sir I've never paid for a car I
always pay cash for a car no you but you
didn't have everything else everything
else you went in debt for so we've got
to get rid of the payment on the plan
here let's get this stuff cleaned up
dude hey well done Kevin appreciate you
calling in we're here to help you if you
need more can call them a good show
thank you sir that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books our thanks to
Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew in the
booth the booth dudes did it again we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Rams and
baby steps go to ramsesolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramseysolutions.com and
click get started
[Music]